aunque menos periodistas han estado en
el campo de batalla este año debido a la
pandemia del cob y del 19 unos 50 fueron
asesinados por hacer su trabajo de
acuerdo con un informe de reporteros sin
fronteras en los últimos años la
proporción de periodistas asesinados en
zonas de guerra ha disminuido al tiempo
que en aquellos países supuestamente
pacíficos se ha incrementado como méxico
india pakistán
honduras o filipinas el país más
peligroso del mundo para ser periodista
sigue siendo méxico donde ocho de ellos
fueron asesinados en 2020 uno de ellos
decapitado y otro descuartizado casi una
decena de comunicadores son asesinados
en este país cada año y los crímenes
quedan en la impunidad es un tipo de 68
por ciento es decir más de dos terceras
partes de los periodistas asesinados
eran de países en paz porque fueron
atacados deliberadamente ellos publican
reportes investigaciones que generan
molestia y debido a que difunden
información que avergüenza a ciertos
gobiernos son atacados deliberadamente y
eliminados viajemos irán afganistán
pakistán e india han tenido el mayor
de periodistas muertos este año incluido
uno en india que fue quemado vivo
recientemente en irán fue el mismo
estado el que mató a un reportero con la
ejecución de rojo la samp editor de un
sitio web de noticias dos más murieron
durante protestas contra la corrupción
de la policía en nigeria como parte de
una nueva tendencia a este año en el que
siete periodistas fueron asesinados en
todo el mundo mientras cubrían
manifestaciones